does a project have to have distribution
before you will
take it on as a producer no um i know a
lot of producers that do that
where they only work on a project if it
has distribution or interest
me i'm not big enough to do that and i
don't think i would do that anyway
because there's a lot of times where
our industry once something goes and
pops off
everybody runs to that right but in like
the art of war if everyone's running and
looking over here what's over here
like you know so if you don't have
distribution it might just be that your
project is just not good enough or it's
a gem
and everyone's looking over here but
that's where they're going to be looking
at next
at this gem that you just found so i
think that even at the highest level um
the producers that don't have that rule
they find those gems and i mean that
from a place i'm not gonna like
i don't wanna name drop but there's a
very specific producer right now like
she's like at the top
and she does that she finds these gems
she meets these directors that like
sundance and she's like what are you
working on
send it over you know like this guy this
weird guy at sundance and
he makes the best like he makes the next
thing that people are looking at and
then you'll see 18 of them pop up
the next year and we stay in that moment
but who found the first
one and that only happens if you find
those things that don't have the
attention so no as a producer i
don't have that rule i do think about
distribution though early on like i said
like if it's
i'm reading a script and i love it but
i'm like who
is going to buy this like i have to to
to dig into that and that doesn't mean
i'm not going to take it on
but i do have to manage expectation of
the of the writer or producer i mean
writer
or director or whoever is a part of it
so far and then also say like hey guys
like if we do this one thing this is
going to feel bad
creatives right you're talking to
creatives this is going to feel bad but
if you make this one change
i can make a whole lot of people see
this because i could probably get this
distributor
if you don't make the change i love it
so much i work on it but
understand if your goal because remember
we talk about i always ask them first
what's your goal in this where do you
see this going if they're like oh i just
wanted to be in theaters and i just want
this
well now we got to have a conversation
this is not going to probably make it to
theaters
and then he just slumped down but if you
make this change
i'll have a better chance to get into
theaters and now we're having a
conversation with a creative that
doesn't want to make any changes
but now they're more motivated because
they want their goal is to get people to
see it or their goal is to get to
this distributor or to get on netflix or
whatever it is so yeah
i think it's important to remain open
but mindful of distribution
is that change usually always include
adding a name talent to the main
character no
jason bloom ruined that no i love jason
bloom um
no it's right now if you're at a big
budget level you definitely need a named
person you need somebody that people
recognize because
you're going to get people to watch this
everywhere
so it's all about the marketing and
nothing else like you just have to
show things people like they want to see
a sex scene they want to see a beautiful
woman they want to see a guy that they
recognize
give it to them but if you're in a
independent space right you're in a
place where you're bringing some art
you're bringing something that connects
with this audience or that audience
there's other motivations here it's not
just the glitz and the glamour it's not
just the color
there are other things that can make
something go like look at blair witch
i mean that thing went nuts and why did
it go nuts you learn that and then you
can apply to other things but
those those moments in time where all
the rules
that people tell us well you need a name
actor you need this we've seen
we've seen things happen without it
there is there is it's not an anomaly
it's only anomaly because it happens so
few and far between because people
aren't taking chances
i recently spoke to someone um that is
i won't say the name of the company but
they're pretty
everyone knows the name of this company
and they said
i love this project but i have to be
honest i would be scared to distribute
it
and i was like what like i'm this little
producer and you're telling me you're
scared i'm not
but they have to be because their job is
literally to make sure something sells
they're not creatives they're not i mean
they could be but that's not their job
their job is to only make sure something
sells
now their next film they make a decision
that head of acquisitions or whatever it
is
they make a decision it doesn't sell
guess what they can get fired
so understanding like there's a job here
that's on the line the only reason
they're telling you no is because
something doesn't necessarily
push us forward so then go back to the
big dream having the ability then
like a harvey weinstein to be able to
find that little gem
and market it in a way that connects
with those niche audiences that connects
with those people that care about more
than that
so it's not just a named actor it's like
tugging on this heartstring
tugging on this political like salacious
moment that we're all experiencing
we're arguing about this let me just
drop a line in the trailer that tells me
that we're going to deal with this
controversial thing and now i want to go
watch it or whatever it is that you know
we play these games of marketing
and then you watch the film you're like
oh it wasn't really about that but i got
you to come because
i focused on these elements that aren't
necessarily are only
an actor a star so it is overcomeable
but of course we're still in the age of
like faces
and people that we know they drive
people to it it's like
i know this woman and actually even the
wife of our executive producer
she's not going if it's not tom cruise
like if it's tom cruise because she's
not she doesn't like going to movies she
likes to watch you know her you know
netflix or whatever but if it's tom
cruise she's getting up and she's going
so you have to keep that in mind but if
you can't afford a tom cruise
the person you think that's going to
bring all these people in is
probably won't so you need that plus
this plus this plus this so focus in on
those other things first
and then try to fit that star into the
budget because and i'm not trying to
focus on tom cruise but it's not tom
cruise if it's not denzel
they're not flocking for it and also
we're live in a time where people can go
watch tom cruise at home now
or denzel at home or will smith at home
or angelina or whoever
so that's not going to get them out to
your movie necessarily
so now you got to think of the other
elements i think it's making this work a
lot more hard
to really dig in and see what people
want so it's a it's a curse
it's a moment where everybody's like
exhausted like what do they want
how to sell this but also it's like it's
a blessing it's like we get to grow in
this moment
as filmmakers and storytellers like i'm
not going to depend on a star
i'm going to depend on how i'm going to
connect with that audience in such a way
that if i just get a good marketing team
to show that i've
got that connection my movie's going to
get seen
and then you got to add in all the other
glitz and glamour of like commercials
and things so pna yeah
so it's a lot a lot of elements too but
the actor
that big actor that makes them come has
been diminished because we're
kind of going into the next era of
ensemble cast
interesting stories that connect to this
group of people you know we're we're
kind of moving away from that because we
we years ago we moved into the age of
realism so when you got realism
happening
in real life it's not all about one
person so how can you bank a whole movie
on one person
unless you're just like the whole
world's in love with them and how many
stars can we actually say right now
everyone's in love with i mean it's like
it used to be just
that was the world like even growing up
watching old movies is like
it's just certain people humphry polgar
right
but where is our humphrey right now
where is our
audrey hepburn my favorite um where are
those people that just
people just are they fell in love with
our hollywood sweethearts our america
sweethearts
where are they they're they're now
getting into that phase of they're also
producing like brad pitt or you know
like it's it's different like
they're getting into new era and then
this newer era of actors and such
they're an ensemble cast they're getting
known on
like it was this actor i was like how do
they have such a big social media file
i've never heard of them
and then someone told me oh they're on
that show on netflix i'm like what
but that girl's not going to sell a
movie i didn't know who she was so so
so many others but if you found that gem
on netflix you have this huge following
you got people following social media
engaging with you
but you can't sell a movie off of her if
you're releasing in theaters
so the people that people are like
attracted to right now
are influencers
that they can watch for free on their
phones so how do we overcome that we
can't only focus on the actor anymore we
have to focus on connecting with them
and something they care about
and that takes a lot more work sometimes
do you think the reason we don't have
the ava gardeners the humphrey bogarts
audrey hepburn says because there is too
much realism and now we know about
everybody's personal life for better or
worse
because that's become part of the
tabloids at the supermarket
and we just can't resist oh wait oh this
hap
oh i just have to see this really
quickly and it ruins it because then we
see they're just like
they're just like us yeah it's like um
it's a
good and bad thing to know that they're
just like us like you know you see in
the magazine they're just like us they
go grocery shopping
that's fun right but you like oh they're
just like my uncle so and so that is
on like some type of drug or they're at
rehab or they're
making a fool of themselves at a party
and you get to watch it the next day on
tmz it's like
it's the glamour is gone it's not the
same i can't say it's gone it's changed
so it's more like wow you're on tv not
wow
you're perfect that doesn't exist
anymore um
so again with the information age that
we are
in that's information across the board
but that also is a lot of exposure
and when you are exposed it's either
gonna be really good or really bad
that's why people hide themselves so
often we can't be vulnerable because
it's exposing ourselves and you're
exposing something
it's something you don't want people to
see so now we're at the state where
it's people being paid to go find things
that people don't want to see
people are being planted in places to
spark that
uh un unnatural or uh
i don't know just ugly desire that this
person has yeah let me go plant someone
to help bring that
into play this is a weird time we're
living in and then we also have
things like me too that people that oh
they lifted them
on these pedestals and they fell in such
a demoralized disgusting way where
you're like
him i followed him with like i would
watch everything he's in so yeah i think
the masses are a little jaded and i
think
as filmmakers we have to accept that
because so many so often they i mean
they still
and i'm like studios are smart they do
it best right
but then they put someone in a film and
they put so much money into it and
they're like
you watch that they just banked on a
star and it didn't work and they do it
again
and again and again so especially in the
independent world we can't make that
decision
we don't have the the capital or the
security to even like have a failure
so we have to be really mindful like hey
let's think holistically about this
let's understand where people
are there's no more wow so-and-so's in
your movie like that's a little less of
a thing
so being mindful yes there are tabloids
there's all these things
that can pull a person down and show us
the realism but also on the flip side
you can also
see some really cool things like how
caring a person is in their philanthropy
or whatever so
so many things about it where they can
just fill out your buddy
but you don't necessarily get really
excited to see your buddy it's a family
familiarity so let's not act like
they're excited to see this actor they
have to be excited to see your film
they have to be excited about your story
and the only way to connect with
someone's excitement
that is proven at any time is to find
out their why to find out their own
motivation
so again going back to knowing the
masses like what are we being motivated
by right now what are we worried about
and the news does it so well i know if
we watch the news and then figure out
what to write about i think
we'll kind of win because the news knows
all right now they're fearful
let's talk about the taliban all day or
now they're upset let's now bring in all
the negative things that were tweeted
it's like well we can do that too as
filmmakers but we could also give a
respite audrey hepburn audrey hepburn
one of the favorite quotes of mine
that she was proud to be in the business
that gives a respite and
we still can do that even though we're
living in an age of realism and we're
giving real stories we can still let
that person escape from their life
by connecting with their feelings and
that's something that we're
so connected now with social media but
there's so much less of a connection
i remember growing up i knew all my
neighbors and down the street like they
could tell me get off my lawn i'm
telling your mom and i knew they were
really serious now like my son i don't
know the neighbors down the street they
would
yell at him i would never hear about it
so we're less connected but more
connected
it's an odd time we're trying to figure
out where we're at we're
even trying to figure out what what the
sexes are now it's so many things
but we as filmmakers have a great
opportunity to capitalize on that in a
way that's not
just for the sake of oh let me
capitalize off of that and make some
money off of it
like some movies that found um a
controversial thing and made a movie but
then it failed because it wasn't
authentic
what is what is it what more that can
you give because the tabloids already
give the salacious like
drama there's reality shows that can
give them drama so what else are you
giving them
where they can take away and we can do
that in a way that no one else can
film is still i think by far the most
comprehensive easiest way to connect
in a two-hour frame and then the story
is over tv is amazing
but your story can go on forever so
you're going to lose people you're going
to gain people
but film is like hey here's the story so
what are we giving with that story we
can give so many things so
just being mindful of those other things
that we can give and then
we're able to get there in that place
where people are watching our films and
people are
celebrating our art and we're getting
more chances and all that
all that though starts with the why like
why the audience likes something where
they're at so
yeah be mindful of the times
you